over the first time we are hearing now
from a Texas woman who was convicted of
murdering her husband a decorated fire
Captain Robert pointer was shot in the
head while sitting in his wife's Jeep on
a rural road back in 2016
chasey pointer told police she called
her husband for help after the Jeep got
stuck in the mud
she claimed he was shot by an unknown
man who emerged in the dark when police
responded to her 911 call body cameras
captured what happened 48 hours Peter
van zan spoke to chasey in her first TV
interview on September 9 2016 a
desperate 911 call a swift response from
the Royse City Texas Police Department
police body cameras captured the moments
after the caller
chasey coiner dialed 9-1-1
sergeant Shayne meek tried to make sense
of chasey story tell us what what
happened your husband what's his name
chasey told sergeant meek she called her
husband Robert a decorated fire captain
after her Jeep got stuck in thick mud
chasey is telling her story for the
first time that night sergeant meek had
a hunch that chasey knew more than she
was saying that some guy just happened
to be standing in the shadows of the
trees to step out and shoot this guy
point-blank in the in the head where the
gun just didn't make sense later at the
police station
chasey was confronted by Detective
Michael Burke prosecutor Jeff Kovac this
is a case about sex lies
money and murder tax estate Allah Peter
Van Zandt is here and videotape we have
to say we ever and that body cam
evidence was key I mean why were cops so
suspicious what did it say
well first off it's where this killing
occurred it's on one of these Farm to
Market roads in Texas they're not made
for cars to go down those big wheeled
tractors tracked vehicles like a tank
can make it down but not a car and
somehow she driven the family car down
there called her husband whom she
planned to meet in town at a jaqen box
and said come help me I'm stuck in the
mud he gets out there and somehow a
stranger comes out of the bushes and
shoots him in the head I stopped at the
wrong Bush yes it's not a laughing
matter but it's a very suspicious story
absolutely and also the way she behaved
on those various cameras this pant
talking she did constantly the the
investigators believe that was all in
acting at times when they would leave
she'd stop come back and she'd begin
again so it's a fascinating unraveling
of this murder we can't wait to watch
Peter van zan thank you so much and you
can see Peters report chasey pointer
witness to murder tomorrow at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS